la mezzo soprano canadienne catherine
daniel qui fait partie de la
distribution de champion a décidé
d'aller à la rencontre des jeunes de
l'école d'ali nestor une école qui
utilisent la boxe comme deuxième chance
pour les jeunes décrochent
rappelez-vous gaz qu'est ce que vous
avez trouvé de plus suprenant quand vous
avez commencé la boxe amateur contre les
coupes colère des jeunes défouler là bas
c'est un jeu c'est un sport de mu script
de force c'est aussi savoir contrôler
ses émotions parce qu'ils avaient
entendu l'histoire des majeures si oui
en 1962 le boxeur noir américain emile
griffith va devenir champion du monde
des poids moyens en battant bénie par
est plongé dans le coma il décédera
quelques jours après le combat
avant le début de l'affrontement paraît
avait insulté griffith en faisant
allusion à son homosexualité ce qui
déchaînera la violence de griffith dans
le rythme durant des années
wii fit devra vivre avec ce décès et les
multiples provocations
rollier à son orientation sexuelle
parfait
je vous invite à venir voir une
répétition de l'opéra au place-des-arts
les siens à répétition je voulais parler
pas trop de l'importance que mentorat
comme emile abessolo son gérant et puis
aussi son entraîneur et il a avec lui
tout le long de sa carrière et c'est eux
qui ont dit à qui sait attendre 1961 en
tête et tout ça et puis c'est la même
chose avec ces jeunes on a besoin d'une
équipe de la communauté qui se croient
qu'ils étaient weeds peu lavables
[Musique]
m
ricardo était encore un peu secoué après
la répétition
la scène où wiifit envoie son adversaire
au tapis est venu ravivé de douloureux
souvenirs ses batteries
mais le narrateur ça veut appeler comme
jean mois commence comme s'est basé
comme j'ai des problèmes mais j'ai fait
un truc pas encore aussi
première manquée la chanteuse d'opéra se
déplacent pour rencontrer c'est quand
même quelque chose parce qu'elle l'opéra
c'est vraiment on veut dire un or
les thèmes abordés dans l'opéra
champions sont la résilience et la
rédemption l'espace d'une journée
ces jeunes ont peut être découvert qu'il
n'était pas tout seul dans leur combat
quotidien
robert frosi radio canada montréal